Steve red is my color don't you think
red is also very lucky color for Chinese
and for Tesla in all seriousness yes
they want to get into China big time
very big time why because it's the
biggest market and in the world and
there's a over 1.3 billion people china
is spending a lot of money doing a lot
rd it's been a lot of money get people
to buy electric vehicles cuz china's a
lot of cities are very polluted right
now let's go for a ride I want to see
how this baby drive
well Steve if you say China is such an
important market what are they doing to
promote v's especially since they have
such a massive pollution problem they
not only subsidizing purchases they're
spending a lot of money on RD to
standardize the charging infrastructure
the battery technology all sorts of
technology I mean are there any
competing technologies to EV right now
oh definitely feel cell has been
catching on very quickly recently we
believe fuel cells still is going to
take a little bit longer to be adopted
you know there's always a concern with
safety fuel cells actually uses hydrogen
as a main source of fuel is very
volatile fuel so there's going to be a
lot of work that needs to be done to
actually get the consumer to get really
comfortable with having hydrogen in
their vehicles all right so drive us
into the future tell us what 2015 is
going to look like for automakers what
should we be looking out for I think
China is those is still going to be a
major market there's a lot of moving
parts in the China market you know we
had two years of strong growth I think
you know and I think consensus believe
that there's going to be a lot of risk
going forward you know there's going to
be limits to new car registration
especially in cities that are highly
polluted very congested you know the
economy is actually slowing down the
growth in the economy is flowing down
your consensus is actually forecasting
GDP the only grow seven percent and
there's been downward revisions
in the past few months to that number